with over 46 million americans using
crypto exchanges cryptocurrency has gone
beyond bitcoin fans and retail investors
they've attracted the irs too despite
market volatility one thing will always
be consistent you have to pay your taxes
but as technology and legislation
evolves what should you know
while crypto wants to be the new
currency it currently is being taxed as
a property every crypto sale creates a
taxable event just like selling a stock
so property is actually an umbrella of
assets equities or property bonds and
commodities and real estate and so what
that means is that there's an influx or
a deflux in value from the time you
obtained a property compared to the time
when you disposed of it and so that
delta is a gain or loss that you have to
track and so it's this notion of cost
basis what was my original obtainment
value compared to when i disposed of it
there's all sorts of complexities around
the world when it comes to tax reporting
it's a really difficult topic because
there's
you know hundreds of countries that
treat cryptocurrency differently as well
as just their whole tax regime expats if
you have you know a u.s a resident or if
you're a citizen you're always going to
be on the hook at some point unless you
hire a tax attorney and go through some
legal structuring and so every person's
facts and circumstances are different
but if you are thinking about moving
offshore for tax savings it's definitely
money well spent to go and get an expert
because there's a lot of entity
structuring and paperwork associated
with that and residency requirements and
all sorts of things you have to have
buttoned up buying and selling crypto is
just one piece of the ecosystem
activities like mining or staking also
come with their own requirements as well
staking is receiving net new assets in
return for putting up your assets and
for collateral and so with the irs as
well as most countries they view that as
you performed an action to receive net
new obtainment of value and so every
time you receive a staking deposit into
your wallet the irs deems that income
and so it's the measurement of the fair
value of when you obtain that
and then you report that on the income
section of your tax return ultimately
when you dispose of it any gain or loss
from that income amount that you
reported is a gain or loss and so
there is this double kind of tracking
mechanism when it comes to staking
deposits
so nfts the rise has been monumental
we're helping millions of people with
nfts and so the reporting requirements
are actually pretty similar they're
collectibles so there's a little bit of
a difference in tax rate if you hold
them for more than a year most people
right now have not held an nft more than
a year most that we're starting to come
up on that so you report the gainer loss
however it's specifically identifiable
you know
nft is usually one of one or one of x
and it's an actual thing uh a
collectible that you own and so you
can't like bitcoin select different lots
representing ownership in different nfts
it's hey you bought this one for x you
sold it for y and you take the
difference and that way it takes that
reporting obligation off of the user to
go and figure it out you just hand it a
form and you're good to go
for now filers can look at crypto like
any other investments from real estate
to equities people think about taxes in
this lens of it's a once a year activity
right i'm gonna go and figure it out all
before april 15th well when it comes to
crypto traders that's kind of an oh crap
moment for lack of better words uh where
they start to plug in things and realize
well i have a tracking nightmare here in
addition to a visibility problem i had
no idea that i was incurring all these
taxable events throughout the year and
now i'm hit with a tax bill all in april
and so it's kind of this unpleasant
experience and so the first thing i tell
people is if you're really using
cryptocurrency as a peer-to-peer
currency high frequency trading or even
just dabbling around the transactions
start to add up and the tracking
complexity starts to add up and your tax
bill sometimes can add up and so engage
an accountant or use a software service
that gives you that real-time visibility